madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce vendredi 20 juillet c'est d'abord la
ville de gênes en italie en proie à de
très violents affrontements en marge du
sommet du g8
un manifestant tué par balles deux
blessés graves
de nombreuses arrestations et dans le
camp retranché les hommes les plus
puissants du monde discute de l'avenir
de la planète
les colonies de vacances tournent tous
fiasco pour les enfants des salariés de
france télécom a rien ne se passe comme
prévu un document dans ce journal à
document qui montre le système très
perfectionné des pots-de-vin entre la
france et l'allemagne dans le cadre de
l' affaire elf et puis la mort de
maurice
le dessinateur et père de lucky luke est
décédé à l'âge de 77 ans
l'extraordinaire déploiement de forces
de la police italienne n'aura donc pas
suffi à assurer le calme à gênes où se
tient le sommet du g8
la violence s'est déchaîné le sang a
coulé un mort deux blessés graves parmi
les manifestants antimondialisation
pascal golomer et gilles jacquier qui
était au coeur de la manifestation avec
un mouvement italien ultra radical ont
été témoins de scènes de guérilla
urbaine très violente
la mort d'un manifestant
c'est ce que redoutait le plus les
organisateurs de ces trois jours de
contestation il a été tué de deux balles
par des carabiniers avant d'être écrasé
par un véhicule de la police à l'écart
de la zone rouge
dans un quartier qui tout l'après midi
fut le théâtre d'affrontements très
violent face à face deux jeunes
manifestants
impossible à identifier
et les forces de l'ordre qui n'ont pas
voulu laisser avancer le cortège
d'écoutés bianche les tuniques blanches
un mouvement radical italien jusqu'au
centre historique qu'il s'était promis
d'envahir les consignes étaient strictes
elle fut respectée le cortège de 15000
personnes a dû rebrousser chemin au prix
d'une répression rarement vus lors d'une
manifestation
faut-il encore parler de manifestations
mais tout est bien ok avait promis de ne
se servir que de leur corps et de leur
main pour se défendre
promesse oubliée une véritable guerre de
position ou la police doit parfois
reculés abandonné même ces véhicules
pour tenter ensuite de prendre le petit
groupe à revers
on est très loin aujourd'hui du
spectacle de manifestations pacifiques
de la veille
et cet affrontement pourrait durer
encore plusieurs heures tant chacun des
deux quand souhaite conserver ses
positions à l'écart de la zone rouge
une charge policière succède à une autre
et le bilan ne cesse de s'alourdir
côté policier côté manifestants surtout
des dizaines de blessés parfois très
gravement
celui-ci attendre à l'ambulance près de
dix minutes
d'autres ce soir sont dans un état très
critique
fallon chalvron et dominique merlin
envoyés spéciaux de france 2 à gènes
étaient eux à l'intérieur de la zone
rouge cette zone qui correspond au coeur
historique de la ville de gênes et où se
tiennent donc les réunions des chefs
d'état leurs reportages dans ce qu'il
faut bien appeler un camp retranché
les manifestants avaient promis de
pénétrer dans la zone rouge et la police
les attendait la wii du 20 septembre
en fait ils sont passés à côté par cette
petite rue latérale
les forces de l'ordre ont bien failli et
de prise de court
les projectiles pleuvent mais les
barrières métalliques ont tenu le coup
et les lances à incendie ont fait le
reste
les manifestants pour l'essentiel des
militants d'attac se sont laissés
dispersés pour se retrouver quelques
minutes plus tard place tente à 100
mètres à peine du palais ducal où les
chefs d'état étaient réunis genova
libera ce mur est une honte
certains réussiront à passer de l'autre
côté
au bout d'une heure et demie la pression
devient trop fort nouvelle offensive des
lances à incendie certains tentent de
résister à la pression
d'autres s'en joue mais au final la zone
rouge ne sera pas franchie alors c'est
évidemment dans ce contexte très
perturbé que se tiennent les réunions
des chefs d'état de ce g8 jacques chirac
a dit sa consternation à propos de ces
incidents
jacques chirac a souligné qu'il fallait
être à l'écouté des revendications des
manifestants antimondialisation sur
place ironie de saintes olive et
jean-paul chaussée
dès l'aéroport ce matin le ton est donné
radar voiture blindée batteries
antimissiles le ciel est sous haute
surveillance
et pour les sept chefs d'état des pays
les plus industrialisés l'accueil est
réduit au strict minimum
jacques chirac et ses pairs vous l'êtes
un sommet ouvert concret à l'ecoute des
grands problèmes de la planète
ils se retrouvent reclus dans un palais
ducal en état de siège
coupé du reste de la ville juste en face
en forme de provocation
un habitant a étendu son linge pourtant
aujourd'hui le président de la
république veut écouter et comprendre
les manifestants transposer le dialogue
social qu'il prône en france sur le plan
international cent vingt mille ou cent
cinquante mille personnes ne se dérange
pas s'il n'y a pas quelque chose qu'il
aura mobilisé le coeur ou l'esprit et si
quelque chose leur a mobilisé le coeur
ont l'esprit il faut comprendre ce que
c'est je ne dis pas qu'ils ont raison ou
tort c'est pas le problème mais c'est
qu'il ya un problème
une angoisse une difficulté ça on ne
peut pas le laisser comme si ça
n'existait pas et en forme de première
réponse pour marquer leur solidarité aux
plus pauvres
les sept ont débloqué cet après-midi
près d'un milliard de dollars un fonds
thérapeutique pour les malades du sida
de la tuberculose et du palu la chirac
se pose un homme de dialogue et veut
convaincre ses partenaires
mais cette stratégie d'ouverture se
heurte déjà ce soir aux débordements et
les drames qui en découlent remettent en
question la tenue même de ce type de
sommets alors on dirait que maintenant
alain de chalvron vous êtes à gènes une
nouvelle fois on l'a vu la violence
s'est déchaîné et en dépit de mesures de
sécurité exceptionnelles
on n'a pas pu éviter le drame je
rappelle le dernier bilan en date un
mort et deux blessés graves alain oui
écoutez c'était prévisible je pourrais
même dire que c'était prévu en tout cas
depuis goteborg
les autorités italiennes s'attendait au
pire le pire est donc arrivé on ne peut
pas leur reprocher de ne pas avoir tout
fait pour l'empêcher depuis un mois un
dialogue intense et nouer avec les et
les ong
beaucoup de concessions ont été faites
notamment sur le droit de manifester ou
d'aller et venir
mais d'un autre côté les italiens
devaient bien assurer la sécurité du
sommet d'où cette idée de cette muraille
de barrières métalliques qui est devenu
un symbole une sorte de bastille à
prendre le symbole rêvé pour ce qui de
toute façon on était venu ici pour
casser
alain il ya eu le précédent de seattle
en 99 tout récemment vous le disiez le
sommet européen de göteborg est ce qu'on
peut encore envisager des réunions
internationales pacifique
écoutez je crois que la question est
posée hier silvio berlusconi le premier
ministre italien nous avait dit que pour
lui ce sommet était devenu un cauchemar
et c'était hier alors que doit-il penser
aujourd'hui il avait dit qu'il se posait
personnellement la question de la
pérennité de ce genre de réunion il
avait ajouté qu'il poserait la question
aux autres chefs d'état c'est dire que
la question doit véritablement être sur
la table des discussions en ce moment
même vous savez à l'origine c'est g7
parce qu'à l'époque c'était simplement
des g7 étaient des sortes de réunions
entre amis on devait parler de tout
d'une manière un petit peu informel il
faut bien reconnaître qu'on en est
maintenant très loin en direct de gênes
à l'homme seul gros merci
ce devait être de jolies colonies de
vacances mais pour les enfants des
salariés de france télécom la ventura
tendance à tourner au fiasco
l'association en charge de ces séjours
d'été n'a pas mis en place la logistique
nécessaire notamment pour le transport
du coup eh bien ce sont les parents eux
mêmes qui sont contraints de jouer les
accompagnateurs laëtitia le genre
tout s est bien passé salariés en colère
contre france télécom sont avant tout
des parents furieux leurs enfants
plusieurs centaines sont partis en
colonie grâce à l'entreprise début
juillet aujourd'hui leur retour n'est
plus assurée les parents vont donc
devoir aller les chercher eux mêmes pas
toujours facile quand on habite à l'eau
bout de la france on ne sait pas comment
ces enfants de revenir alors
jean-françois ou en corse et en floride
mais les plus gros problème se situe sur
les les lieux de séjour en france où on
demande aux parents d'aller les chercher
aux quatre coins de la france ils nous
ont dit si vous voulez récupérer les
enfants souvenirs à toulouse et chercher
et si vous ne pouvez pas si je ne peux
pas y mettre commissariat de police
pourtant sur le papier le programme
avait de quoi faire rêver plus d'une
centaine de destinations en france ou à
l'étranger
mais l'association organisatrice agora
junior financé par france télécom est
géré par les syndicats mais plus capable
de faire face à ses responsabilités
les séjours seront assurés normalement
mais plus aucun transport d'enfants
il est organisé à partir de maintenant
je pense comme il faut pas non plus
esquiver sur la responsabilité parentale
quand il ya une situation difficile en
effet je pense que les parents sont
responsables des enfants les parents
devraient être indemnisés pour leurs
déplacements mais pas pour les congés
quitte rendront à cet effet en tout plus
de dix mille enfants sont concernés par
ces dysfonctionnements les jolies
colonies de vacances ne le sont pas pour
tout le monde il était décidément
propice au rêve party et la météo
n'altère pas l'enthousiasmé des fans de
musique techno c'est dans le finistère
cette fois-ci qu'un millier de
participants se sont rassemblés en marge
d'un festival de rock
après les deux accidents tragiques de
ces dernières semaines la préfecture du
finistère mettant en garde les
organisateurs thomas dandois et josé
boulesteix
ce sont surtout les fous de techno
bretons qui sont là fidèles au rendez
vous dans la nuit ils ont planté leurs
murs d'enceinte près de locmaria berrien
en forêt armoricaine les autres doivent
arriver plus tard l'année dernière
l'événement avait rassemblé trente mille
personnes
cette année on annonce le chiffre
astronomique de 50000 rêveur difficile
pourtant de confirmer la rumeur car le
monde de la rave party cultive un
sérieux du pour le ce des organisateurs
il n'ya pas y apporte organisateurs
il n'y a pas d'organisateur c'est comme
ça ça mouvement les gens se bougent ils
se posent les gendarmes basés à quelques
kilomètres des lieux font quelques
apparitions à défaut d'interdire le
rassemblement il tente de faire
appliquer les règles de sécurité
élémentaires
le but pour nous dans un premier temps
s'il voulait c'est de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse avoir des voix libres pour
pouvoir acheminer les secours jusque là
un cas de besoin si jamais les pompiers
le samu ou d'autres ont besoin de ont
besoin bien évidemment de venir sur le
sur les lieux la rave s'est installé sur
une ancienne mine de plomb un site
totalement inappropriée selon le maire
de la commune
un maire qui ne cache pas son agacement
face à ce type de mouvement c'est un
site dangereux et il ya également un
environnement il ya des habitants qui
habitent à 1 320 dollars ça leur
rapporte que des nuisances sonores qui
sont indiscutables c'est la quatrième
fois que ça se reproduit en amour en fin
d'après-midi les rêveurs finissent par
quitter les lieux
on parle alors de plusieurs points de
rendez-vous et même d'un éclatement de
la rave
mais finalement c'est vers la bretagne
sud que le mouvement semble se déplacer
vers un champ suffisamment grand cette
fois pour accueillir l'ensemble du
teknival
à la préfecture de police de paris on
prend très au sérieux les deux
explosions qui ont visé ces derniers
jours deux commissariats de banlieue un
télégramme appelant les fonctionnaires
de police à la vigilance a été diffusée
à tous les services
mathias hillion et guillaume viard
c'était le 31 mars dernier une bombe
artisanale détruisez le véhicule d'un
agent de la brigade anticriminalité de
nanterre dans la nuit du 14 au 15
juillet de nouveaux attentats ont visé
la police à champigny l'engin explosif
était placé sous une voiture de
patrouille
cattier habite juste au dessus du
commissariat la détonation la réveiller
à 3h30 du matin
flic est sorti avec alain c'est le
soldat light en jeu suite au succès du
feu et puis il y avait toute les patrons
qui sont arrivés puis voilà quoi ça fait
comme un boom comme c'était comme si que
c'était le bâtiment qui allaient
exploser à saint denis cette même nuit
du 14 juillet c'est contre la façade du
commissariat que la bombe de faible
puissance étaient placés pour les
syndicats de policiers cette montée de
la délinquance ne peut plus durer
j'ai lancé exercée contre les
fonctionnaires de police sont de plus en
plus vieux grave et sérieuse certains
fonctionnaires de police sont contraints
après des arrestations effectuées sont
contraints voix et leurs véhicules
brûlés incendié certains sont contraints
de déménager
comment voulez vous que les
fonctionnaires de police assurent la
sécurité des citoyens alors qu'ils ne
font pas sécurisé eux mêmes
après ces deux attentats et un week end
pendant lequel les pompiers n'ont pu
intervenir dans certaines cités
qu'encadré par des crs
la préfecture de police de paris appelle
ses agents à la plus grande vigilance
un document dans ce journal à documents
concernant l' affaire elf et ses
innombrables prolongation à l'étranger
pour la première fois le très organisés
système de pots-de-vin entre la france
et l'allemagne est dévoilé au grand jour
il retrace le parcours des flux
financiers de la corruption
mais en dépit de ces informations la
justice allemande tarde à donner suite
en quête soliver caroff et jean nicol
seuls quelques magistrats ont pu voir ce
document jusqu'à présent
sous vos yeux l'argent noir du groupe
elle compte bancaire après comptes
bancaires de virements retraits
d'espèces tout est détaillé au centime
près
un labyrinthe irrigué par des centaines
de millions de francs
les commissions occultes versées par elf
au début des années 90
pour dresser ce tableau il a fallu
quatre années de travail au juge suisse
paul perraudin silencieux face à la
presse obstiné devant ces dossiers qui
la démonter la mécanique financière de
l'affairé elf en suivant les traces de
l'argent il a trouvé des pistes
politiques exemple ce million et demi de
francs suisses
versée par un intermédiaire du groupe
elf à un certain ludwig holger falt un
membre éminent des anciens gouvernement
d'helmut kohl
il a envoyé l'argent sur l'un de ses
comptes en banque à zurich
quant à t-il fait mystère l'argent a
quitté la suisse destination inconnue
qui est le bénéficiaire final c'est aux
allemands maintenant de poursuivre l'
enquête à genève au palais de justice on
est prêt depuis longtemps à les aider
mais les magistrats allemands ne veulent
rien demandé alors que l'ex cuisse leur
avons fourni comme la loi sus nous le
permet en automne de l'année dernière
tous les détails toutes les informations
plus possédions et qui concerne à des
ressortissants allemands ou des flux
financiers en allemagne
toujours pas de réponse dans la mesure
où le taux allemand ne font pas leur
part du travail en résultent ne pas
connaître toute la vérité quant à la
reprise par elf de ces sociétés
allemandes
cette société allemande s'appelle li na
pour avoir cette raffinerie el fahs
verset 256 millions de francs de
commissions
principaux bénéficiaires deux anciens
agents secrets
un allemand dieter holder est un
français pierre laitiers les deux hommes
nient tout financement politique
mais les juges suisses je pense avoir
prouvé le contraire dans cette note
confidentielle paul perraudin dresse une
liste d'anciens ministres allemands ces
personnes ont reçu les montants évoqués
sous le nom de code observatoire
est-allemand le juge ajoute que d'autres
personnes de nationalité française ont
également reçu sous ce même nom de code
d'importants avoirs
un pseudo observatoire pour verser des
pots-de-vin des deux côtés de la
frontière
à paris le juge van ruymbeke exploite la
piste
côté allemand cette volonté manque
cruellement comme si la belle entente
franco allemande était réservé à la
politique à l'économie mais surtout pas
à la justice
oui et justement la justice huit suisses
s'apprêtent à remettre dès ce soir au un
parquet allemand une soixantaine de
documents sur cette affaire elf parmi
lesquels les pièces que vous venez de
voir de quoi intéresser donc au plus
haut point la commission d' enquête
parlementaire au travail outre-rhin mais
aussi la justice française l'ancien
gourou hippie américain arrivera à une
borne est arrivé cet après midi à
philadelphie après avoir été extradé de
france
retour à la case départ après vingt ans
de cavale pour celui qui a été condamné
par la justice américaine et par
contumace en 93 à la prison à vie pour
le meurtre de son ancienne petite amie
des milliers de personnes ont assisté
aux obsèques des trois palestiniens dont
un bébé de trois mois tué hier dans un
attentat attribué à des colons juifs
extrémistes l'attaqué a eu lieu près de
hébron en cisjordanie et la géographie
des lieux une colonie juive
entouré par des villages palestiniens
démontre l'inextricable situation de ce
proche orient où chaque joueur frappe la
violence charles enderlin
les obsèques se sont déroulées à ida un
village proche de hébron
le nourrisson tué hier soir est porté
par son grand père
viennent ensuite les corps du jeune
homme qui venait de se marier et de son
cousin
des milliers de personnes participent
pour pu les rails au prix de palestine
palestine et aussi nous vengerons nos
martyrs
l'attentât a eu lieu peu avant 23 heures
hier soir les terroristes ont tiré sur
une fourgonnette transportant une
famille palestinienne qui revenait d'un
mariage
quatre autres personnes ont été blessées
parmi lesquelles deux enfants riehl mais
halte mezze raconte à l'entrée du
village les passagers d'une voiture
blanche 12 ans fait signe de passer
c'est alors qu'ils ont ouvert le feu la
voiture des assaillants a pris la fuite
elle est passée par ce barrage militaire
israélien avant de disparaître dans la
direction d'une ville israélienne
l'autorité palestinienne rejette la
responsabilité de cet attentat sur le
gouvernement sharon mais tous les porte
parole israélien a condamné l' attaque
et promis que les terroristes seront
traduits en justice
à hébron après les obsèques de ce matin
elle est dure accrochages armés hier un
calme menaçant régnait sur la ville
face à une telle situation les
dirigeants palestiniens réclament le
déploiement sur chances des observateurs
internationaux proposée par le g8
ariel sharon
deuxième vol d'essai pour un concorde de
la british airways cet après midi
c'était au dessus de l'atlantique nord
un vol la vitesse supersonique d'une
durée de 3 heures 20 qui avait pour but
de recréer les conditions d'une liaison
transatlantique tout vol commercial vous
le savez toujours interdite depuis
l'accident d'il ya tout juste un an à
roissy 90% des vols d'air littoral
annulés aujourd'hui préavis de grève
lancé à l'appel du syndicat national des
pilotes de ligne de la compagnie une
compagne en difficulté et dont marc
dufour l'ancien pdg avait obtenu la
reprise mais selon le syndicat les deux
autres offres de reprise n'ont pas été
étudiées suffisamment nathalie jourdan
et frédéric cerulli décollera décollera
pas au comptoir d'air littoral à nice
la valse-hésitation aura forcé certains
passagers à récupérer leurs bagages
après l'enregistrement ya pas de voile
somme envoyée
je suis pas qu'on va prendre un taxi
mais on va arriver après on l'a dans les
cévennes on va arriver à 11 heures du
soir 90% des vols annulés le mouvement
de grève des pilotes de la compagnie est
particulièrement suivi leur syndicat
exige que l'actuel propriétaire d'un
littoral à essert groupe réexamine les
trois offres de reprise le plan
actuellement retenu celui de l'ancien
pdg de la compagnie marc dufour envisage
la suppression de 300 postes
les autres repreneurs n'en prévoit pas
moins ils ont pourtant la faveur des
pilotes les plans de reprise qui ont été
évincés semble assurée des perspectives
de développement qui sont énormes et qui
permettrait de réembaucher dans les plus
brefs délais les personnels navigants
comme les personnels sol qui auraient
été licenciés cette grève va m'amener à
prendre d'autres dispositions parce
qu'il va bien falloir récupérer l'argent
que perd tous les jours air littoral
je crois qu'on va pas dans le bon sens
en continuant des ventes de ce type là
marc dufour menaçant se considère donc
toujours comme le futur repreneur de la
compagnie sr groupe devra le confirmer
le 27 juillet prochain les pilotes eux
continueront leur mouvement jusqu'à
dimanche soir au moins
offensive du groupe hachette pour
contrer l'hégémonie de la fnac dans le
secteur des biens culturels le groupe
lagardère s'apprête à racheter les 18
magasins virgin en france une réunion du
comité d'entreprise s'est tenu
aujourd'hui sur ce thème douloureuse
révision pour le ministère de l'économie
face au ralentissement de la croissance
bercy table sur un manque à gagner de 25
milliards de francs cette année en
termes de recettes fiscales du coup
c'est mécanique le déficit augmente un
casse tête pour le gouvernement à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
ça ferait mauvais genre d'augmenter les
impôts amaury guibert
il ya un an quand elle faisait la une
des journaux la fameuse cagnotte
la croissance était forte les recettes
fiscales dépassé toutes les espérances
on disait l'état assis sur un tas d'or
un an plus tard l'optimisme est retombé
au ministère des finances la croissance
s'essouffle et les recettes prennent
l'eau d'abord à cause de l'essence cette
année la taxe intérieure sur les
produits pétroliers la tei pépé va
rapporter 10 milliards de francs de
moins que prévu
ils croissance molle c'est aussi moins
de bénéfices pour les entreprises manque
à gagner pour l'impôt sur les sociétés
et de là encore 10 milliards de francs
et enfin 10 autres milliards de moins
pour la tva que l'état a dû davantage
rembourser aux entreprises mais au total
ces aléas budgétaires ne devrait pas
remettre en cause les baisses d'impôts
déjà voté si jamais on devait rentrer
dans une phase de mauvaise conjoncture
durable là il faudra revoir la politique
monétaire mais on n'est vraiment pas
aujourd'hui dans cette lettre dans ce
cadre là on est dans le cadre d'un
accident conjoncturel donc pour le
traiter comme un accident c'est à dire
dans rechange et toute la politique
économique
d'autant que l'on s'attend un surcroît
de recettes de 5 milliards de francs
pour d'autres impôts notamment l'impôt
sur le revenu au total le manque à
gagner se chiffre à 25 milliards à moins
d'un an des élections le gouvernement ne
prendra pas de mesures impopulaires
en espérant que la croissance reparte
sur de bons rails
25 ans après sa création le
conservatoire du littoral peut se
targuer d'un bilan très positif il a
réussi a freiné le bétonnage des côtes
françaises
en rachetant de très nombreux terrains
en bord de mer pourtant promis à la
spéculation immobilière mais le combat
avec les bétonneurs est un combat de
tous les jours
les moyens du conservatoire sont
limitées un rapport remis aujourd'hui au
premier ministre plaide pour le
doublement des crédits en guérit lune et
y croire et pourtant la poigne jura est
redevenu sauvage précieuses offerte aux
seuls amoureux d'un site exceptionnel
il ya encore dix ans la pointe du raz
c'était cela livré aux bétonneurs aux
marchands au tourisme de masse le salut
viendra du conservatoire du littoral
l'institution achète le site dans les
années 90 elle en chasse tous les
marchands à coups de pelleteuse la
pointe du raz devient inconstructibles
avis elle redevient cette terre vierge
qu'elle fut à l'origine le conservatoire
du littoral c'est cette poignée d'hommes
une cinquantaine qui partent en croisade
contre les promoteurs
aujourd'hui l'organisme fait son bilan
et peut en être fier il a acheté 810 km
de côtes
mais voilà ces croisés d'un genre
nouveau s'essouffle faute de moyens nous
sommes cinquante et un 51 une personne
sur les crédits de l'état auquel
s'ajoute une cinquantaine de personnes
traitées par les collectivités locales
et nous signons un acte d'acquisition
par jour c'est à dire que nous sommes
efficaces il faut doubler ses effectifs
et c'est ce que propose de lui le pensec
l'ennemi est naze puissant le béton
continuent d'envahir les côtes
alors pour lutter à armes égales avec
les promoteurs il faut aussi de l'argent
c'est chose acquise aujourd'hui le
conservatoire aura en plus des hommes un
budget annuel de 300 millions de francs
bref les moyens de son ambition et son
ambition la voile à protéger les
paradisiaque mais plus encore sauvé de
nouvelles terres l'objectif du
conservatoire acheté 30 % du littoral
sauvage ce littoral que les bétonneurs
ne sont pas encore parvenues à souiller
le dessinateur maurice est mort lundi
dernier à bruxelles à l'âge de 77 ans
mais on l'apprend qu'aujourd'hui maurice
est le père d'un héros mythiques de la
bande dessinée c'est lui qui avait créé
juste après guerre
lucky luke le cow-boy qui tire plus vite
que son ombre évocation avec frédéric
bonnet on disait qu'il était un cow boy
solitaire et non avez raison mais
aujourd'hui avec la disparition de celui
qui en a fait un héros légendaire lucky
luke subi le premier grand drame de son
existence
c'est en 47 que maurice a donné à lui
qui luttent la première chance de sa vie
en un demi-siècle notre cowboy a su
évoluer avec son temps
il a surtout connu une ascension
fulgurante grâce également à rené
goscinny qui fut son premier scénariste
jusqu'à sa mort en 77
c'est lui la perte d'avoir du premier
s'est assaini l'humeur ensuite j'ai vu
celle de charlier est arrivée celle de
greg celle de temps et franck un seul le
pays où la banque grecque
franquin d'ailleurs donc je suis un peu
l'impression d'être un arbre dans la
forêt qui voilà tous les arbres
descendrait qui se trouve un peu à peu
isolés
maurice était le dernier auteur mythique
de l'école belge ici à bruxelles tous
ses admirateurs sont conscients de la
carrière internationale de lucky luke
mais celui qui a séduit plus de 300
millions de lecteurs à travers le monde
reste avant tout un enfant du pays
c'est resté je crois que toute sa vie un
petit garçon bruxelles en tire un petit
belge qui avait des rêves trop grand
pour lui et qui les a exposés qui les a
donnés à voir passer notre enfance c'est
un personnage et quand il était petit
quelque chose qui a grandi avec nous
pour finir qui n'a jamais vieilli que
l'on explique à nos enfants et que nous
en font plaisir à l'île maurice avait
l'âme d'un cowboy même s'il ne s'est
jamais identifié à son héros la
personnalité de lucky luke a d'ailleurs
largement été influencé par la pression
que maurice pour le western et à gary
cooper
mais la disparition de maurice
n'empêchera pas notre cowboy de
continuer sa route plus solidaires que
jamais pour de prochaines aventures
animées une journée de repos et voilà
que les coureurs du tour de france
attaqué aujourd'hui au deuxième gros
morceau de l'épreuve avec la première
étape pyrénéenne 166 km entre perpignan
et ax-les-thermes victoire du colombien
cardenas abandon du français christophe
moreau françois simon lui est toujours
en jaune
une étape marquée par une chute très
sérieuse d'un coureur de l'équipe
rabobank
ces stèles bertrand et bruno l'hiver
tout voilà donc la principale différence
entre ullrich et armstrong dernière
ascension l'allemand est en plein effort
l'américain lui et comme sur un vélo
climatisés le duel tant attendu tant
annoncée prend corps dans les pyrénées
les deux favoris ce test s'observe pas
très longtemps en fait à mme sonde met
fin au suspense
il en est presque arrogant de facilité
de puissance on pourrait l'oublier
la route est encore en pente ou le riche
terminent quatrièmes derrière armstrong
l'allemand est un peu vexé mais il ne
dit pas encore son dernier mot je
voulais attaquer plus tôt j'aurais pu
savoir lequel des deux était le meilleur
lens m'a pris trente secondes je vais
encore essayer demain christophe mon
rôle vie ne sera pas là demain quatrième
l'année dernière le français jette
l'épongé son vélo 60 kilomètres après le
départ
le français souffre de problèmes
pulmonaires
les routes sinueuses et étroites en ont
fait chuter plus d'un ici c'est une
fracture de la clavicule un peu plus tôt
de groot heures un rocher de la tête
tombe dans le coma il souffre d'un grave
traumatisme au visage de son côté
françois simon limite les dégâts il perd
4 minutes sur un tronc dit lui en reste
encore neuf d'avant son maillot jaune
est en sursis une journée
corps mais le tout premier de la journée
à franchir la ligne s'appelle félix
gardénia si les colombiens c'est sa
première victoire et elle a bien failli
passer inaperçu oui on apprend qu'une
petite fille d'une douzaine d'années a
été victime d'une fracture de la jambe
au km 133 de cette 12e étape du tour de
france a été percuté par un motard alors
qu'elle voulait ramasser un bidonville
lancé par un coureur en sicile la lave
de l'etna se rapproche dangereusement de
certaines zones habitées sur les flancs
du volcan intense activité depuis le
début de l'année sur le plus haut volcan
d'europe
un spectacle dont profite beaucoup de
touristes olivier pons les
spectaculaires le volcan le plus haut
d'europe où nous rappelle qu'il est bien
vivant à plus de 2000 mètres d'altitude
une nouvelle faille s'est ouverte c'est
la quatrième coulé depuis le début de
l'éruption
pour l'instant un touriste d'imprudents
a été grièvement blessé il a été
transféré à l'hôpital mais cela n'a pas
empêché les italiens de montée par
centaines sur les flancs du volcan
la dernière éruption de cette ampleur
remonte à 1992
les installations touristiques sont
menacés comme ce restaurant panoramique
qui a été préventivement évacuées selon
les autorités italiennes cependant la
situation est loin d'être catastrophique
et les habitants de la région n'ont rien
à craindre ils peuvent donc en toute
tranquillité admirez ces fontaines de
laves intarissable seule crainte pour le
moment la coulée est désormais à moins
de 8 kilomètres du village de nicolo ci
situé en contrebas
les vacanciers de ce mois de juillet ne
sont pas les seuls à se plaindre des
intempéries pour les organisateurs de
festivals en plein air les averses les
orages perturbe sérieusement leurs
manifestations comme ça a été le cas par
exemple mercredi soir la rochelle où le
grand concert de clôture des
francofolies avec henri salvador et
claude nougaro a dû être annulé les
pertes financières sont importantes car
il faut rembourser les spectateurs et
les assureurs rechignent de plus en plus
à payer la note
enquête tania watine et christophe
vallon bras les trombes d'eau
un vent à plus de 100 kilomètres heures
les organisateurs des eurockéennes de
belfort n'ont pas le choix
il faut arrêter le concert puis réparer
les dégâts et rembourser 20 mille
spectateurs ou dans la cagnotte deux
millions et demi de francs une semaine
plus tard à la rochelle les deux
derniers jours des francofolies sont
annulés pour cause de tempête
une fois la sécurité du public assurée
il faut penser à le dédommager les
démarches et j'aborde de rembourser les
gens qui avaient acheté des billets pour
tous les deux spectacles annulés
donc aujourd'hui ils ont tous par
communiqué de presse reçu une adresse et
la manière dont on pouvait organiser ça
une fois le spectacle annulé c'est donc
l'assureur qui entre en scène
mais depuis trois ans il est de plus en
plus sollicités à cause des caprices de
la météo
beaucoup d'assureurs ont perdu
énormément d'argent mais quand je lis
énormément c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
aucune possibilité dans les dix ans à
venir afin de pouvoir récupérer des
pertes qu'ils ont encaissés pendant ces
trois dernières années dont ils
préfèrent abandonner ce type de risque
si jamais les assureurs ne freine plus
série ce que ça peut mettre en péril
toute l'activité des spectacles en plein
air alors les festivaliers tentent de
s'adapter je me demande aujourd'hui très
sérieusement si le festival où tout va
changer un peu de nature et le trouver
un équilibre différent entre des
formations en plein air et les
programmations en france mais la
majorité des festivals ne dispose pas de
salle de spectacle c'est vrai que le
tour n'est pas toujours de la partie
mais heureusement il ya tout de même des
festivals qui se passe bien comme celui
organisé à sablé dans la sarthe pour
7500 enfants le thème du festival c'est
le rock pur et dur
une sorte de mini woodstock en culottes
courtes dominique barrau chez patrice
projet malgré la pluie tombée les trois
jours précédents les enfants sont venus
par milliers les en ciré du coup même le
soleil s'est décidé à pointer chauffe
marcel chaud
et
la famille
tant que les petits se sont très vite
adaptés
les sacs poubelles devait protéger les
petites fesses de l'herbe mouillée
recycler les parapluies pareil
les organisateurs y ont pu les
participants aussi y avait à l'abri
n'était ni trafic de bonbons ni
contrebande de cigarettes en chocolat
on a carburé à l'autre toute la journée
ambiance 40
on entend des gens qu'on ne sait pas à
ce rassemblement rock on retrouve les
enfants des enfants de la génération
woodstock
ça vient comme quoi mais nous on repère
ou stocke tous les temps et puis on en
est à la troisième génération d'enfants
gâtés par la météo pour le 20e
anniversaire de roe qui simule les
enfants non plus plein les oreilles et
non les yeux encore une fois voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal je vous en rappelle
l'actualité dramatique à gênes en italie
très violents affrontements en marge du
sommet du g8
un manifestant tué par balles deux
blessés graves bilan encore provisoire
de nombreuses arrestations jacques
chirac exprime sa consternation et on
apprend à l'instant qu'une fausse alerte
à la bombe a contraint les autorités à
évacuer le centre de presse officielle
de ce gène ikke donc fausse alerte à la
bombe dans un instant la météo avec
patrice drevet qui nous annonce une
amélioration du temps c'est pas trop tôt
suivi du poids route de valérie maurice
rouge demain dans le sens des départs
rathore 50 votre série pj une heure le
dernier journal avec alexandre kara
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13h excellente
soirée sur france 2